years ago i was at a party chatting with
a very famous person who shall remain
nameless by the way good morning heck
it's tuesday today's video is like
gulliver's travels it comes to you in
four parts so anyway after chatting for
a minute the very famous person said to
me i'm sorry to ask this but are you the
science one or the other one and i said
that i was the other one because hank
you have always been the science one
like even when we were kids you had an
early web page called the hank green
mars exploration page while i was into
writing and history and pretty much
anything that wasn't science and yet in
the last few years i found myself
reading a lot of books about science and
choosing to learn about subjects that i
actively hated when i was a student not
only that but a large ecommerce platform
recently named the anthropocene reviewed
book one of the best science books of
the year that's right hank now i am the
science one there are two science ones
and two writer ones now to be fair i'm
not positive that the anthropocene
reviewed is in fact a science book
there's a lot of memoir and literary
analysis and history but there is some
science and the reason i was so pleased
about this isn't just because somebody
named the anthropocene reviewed one of
their favorite books of the year but
also because i love science writing it
deepens my understanding of the universe
and my place in it by the way it would
absolutely shock my 20 or 30 year old
self that i enjoy reading about science
or that i have even arguably written a
science book but those selves would also
be surprised that i loved living in
indianapolis or that i stopped having
stage fright a few years ago or that i
started to love third tier english
soccer here's another example of what i
mean hank you have so many ideas that
there is literally a website called days
since hank green started
hankgreenstartedathing.com and in a
recent vlogbrothers video i was like
hank has an idea every 20 minutes and my
job is to tell him when they are bad but
in the comments of that video a long
time nerdfighter pointed out that 13
years ago i had a somewhat different
take on that subject it has to be said
that i have a crazy idea at least once
every 45 minutes and i count on hank to
be like that is a terrible idea so again
something that feels super fundamental
hank is the ideal one turns out to have
changed over time really so much of what
i consider myself just isn't inevitable
some of it is of course but not all of
it people can change and they can
continue to change the way things are
both for ourselves and for the world is
not the way things always must be which
brings me to part two that was a long
part one partners in health sierra
leone's annual report just came out and
i really recommend reading it or if you
prefer watching to reading there is also
a great video about improvements in
maternal and child care at coitu
government hospital and what the
maternal center of excellence will mean
for that community there have been big
reductions in child and maternal
mortality at coitu government hospital
over the last year which we hope will be
accelerated by the opening of the
maternal center of excellence in 2023
and far more people are using the
healthcare system because they finally
feel like they can actually get care
it's super encouraging plus the letter
from pihc sierra leone executive
director dr byler berry is so beautiful
there's a link to read it in the
doobly-doo also if here at the end of
the year you're in a position to join
the thousands of nerdfighters who make
monthly or one-time donations to support
pih's efforts to radically reduce
maternal mortality pih.org hank and john
part 3 hank and i will both be taking
next week off from vlogbrothers meaning
that this is my last video of 2021 i
would like to say good riddance to 2021
but that would imply a level of like
confidence or welcoming around 2022
and
yeah i don't know what else to say about
that except that i give 2021 two stars
it's sort of like if they made cats too
like it probably wouldn't be as bad but
it would still be a cat's movie part
four the outro i only said this video
had four parts so i could make that
stupid gulliver's travels joke at the
beginning but no regrets hank i will see
you on friday and you will see me in
cats 3 coming soon to theaters